do you think Jesus actually died was
dead for three days and came back to
life
literally yes why would you believe that
long
story I'm
[Music]
sorry I'm a Christian myself but I'm you
know if people want to say well actually
you Sophie you should be this kind of
religious person or or maybe no kind of
religious person at all you should get
your sense to Transcendent outside
religion my response to that is okay
let's talk you know I think I'll quote
the great philosopher Douglas
Adams you know isn't it enough that the
garden is beautiful you don't have to
believe there's fairies at the bottom of
it you know why do we have to add the
woooo stuff why do we have to add the
supernatural the Paranormal first of all
there's no reason to believe it exists
at all and if it does then show us the
evidence for it this is a kind of a
scientific way of thinking about these
things is it true so since Sophie Grace
uh said she's a Christian let me ask you
do you think Jesus actually died was
dead for three days and came back to
life
literally yes why would you believe that
long
story I'm
sorry I used to believe it I was a born
again Christian for seven years and I
just decided I don't think happened now
if somebody says well it happened
mythically or it's metaphorically true
Joseph Campbell Jordan Peterson kind of
this is my pragmatic truth it works for
me I'm not trying to claim it's
literally true all right I can see some
value in that but I don't want to
believe things unless they're actually
true and and unless it's in some other
realm like a political truth you know
what's the right percentage of
immigration in any there's no scientific
answer to that question
uh or you know religion has certain
truths about it that we can't prove but
they're my truths
okay but I would accept Jesus as my
savior if you could convince me it
actually happened go the longer version
and more serious version of that is
actually another bit of Vicken Stein
where he says for these facts to be um
of religious significance for you they
would have to occupy a completely
different place in your life and that's
why it's long story because it's it
doesn't suffice for um faith in any
religion not just Christianity but any
religion or indeed any new spirituality
it doesn't suffice for faith in that
that you should believe a set of facts
and in that sense I don't believe it is
about a set of facts it's about an
existential orientation to what you take
to be facts um which as a matter of
sober history may or may not have
happened in the historical record so you
are constantly attemp in at least I
think if you're sane and critical you
constantly attempt you to keep your mind
open and to say well let's go on talking
you have this very different perspective
on religion from me I would want to say
to someone like Michael that a lot of
the time you're you're just pushing it
an open door because that's not where
that's not what it's about for me being
a Christian that's not where it comes
from and I imagine for people who
Embrace new spiritualities it's not
where they're coming from either it's
not about bold facts I mean as if you
know sort of Cosmic parking tickets are
issued look I've got the parking ticket
here's the proof well you you know if
you are a Christian and you believe when
you die you're going to be up there with
Jesus what's up there is it your body is
it your soul this is the I say the same
thing to the Mind uploading people
what's going up there you know you scan
your connect Dome and you upload it to
the cloud you're still here you know the
point of view self is still right down
here that's just a copy so do you
believe that it's a copy of you up there
afterwards or is it actually you and
what does that mean um well I think that
what I believe about um eternal life is
that I don't know very much about it but
the hope and the promises there in the
faith that I hold so we'll see well I'm
kind of hoping I get to see you to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit I a.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas